Speaker 1: Let's get back to the phones.
And by phones, I don't really mean phones.
I mean discord because we use discord now.
And we are going to hear from some people
just as a reminder to everybody who's
waiting in the waiting lobby. If you have
a nickname, if you have, you know, some
kind of joke or whatever the case may be,
I will not be going to you. So it's totally fine
to have your nickname or whatever. I see people
with all sorts of nicknames. You're just your name
has to be in the format of your name and where
you're calling from in order to be eligible
to get on with me today. Along those lines,
let's go to Sam from Minnesota. Sam, thank you
for sticking to the rules with your nickname.
Speaker 3: Oh, yeah.
Speaker 1: How's my volume?
Your volumes? Pretty. Pretty. Okay. Yeah.
Speaker 3: All right. So I guess one just a
minnesota question. We've we've been on top of the
voting turnout for quite a while, I think the last
five, six, seven. No, I think Main beat us back
in 2010 anyway. So we have had the best turnout.
Do you think that'll if turnout continues to
skyrocket, do you think we'll stay on top or do
you think we might lose out to somebody? You know.
Speaker 1: That's a very interesting question. I
didn't know, but you were right. It
looks like the top turnout in the US
in 2022. Now, what does this include? I guess this
must be primaries. It's Minnesota, New Jersey.
And Oregon. Is that does that sound right to you?
The top turnout states. Very, very interesting.
Speaker 3: New Jersey was so high the last general
in 2020, Maine was second place. But New Jersey
in New Jersey would be really skyrocketing
if they were number two because they were.
Speaker 1: You know what I'm seeing? I'm seeing
New Jersey's number one at 85% and Minnesota's
number two at 83%. Can you believe that?
Speaker 3: 80. Wow. If New Jersey is in the
eighties, that's pretty crazy. Yeah, they must
have some really determined primary goers. Yeah.
Speaker 1: So, Bay, so now that I have the
data in front of me, what was your question?
Speaker 3: Well, just in the general,
do you think Minnesota will stay on
top of anything is going to be New Jersey?
Speaker 1: I have no idea. I mean, listen, I don't
know the dynamics of the you've got like primary
in general. I think that all of these states are
going to be high. Part of it is the relationship
between what is the process to register to vote
versus how likely are you to go and vote. So
there's this I my instinct is there's this
kind of reverse mechanism where if it's harder
to register to vote, which I'm against. Right.
I think it should be really easy to register.
But if it's harder to register, your turnout
as a share of registered voters might end up
being higher because there's sort of like more
obstacles to get registered. So you're probably
more enthusiastic about voting. So I don't know
enough about voter registration process in New
Jersey, Minnesota, Mississippi, Oregon, which are
the top four turnout states. I think we're just
basically guessing and we have to wait and see.
Speaker 3: Yeah, I, I think I'm not so sure
about automatic registration, but like same
day registration where you walk in to vote
and you're like, Oh, I'm not registered. Well,
let me just register then. Yeah, it's, it's
incomprehensible to me that anybody that doesn't
do that, Minnesota does. And we've done
it since the seventies. Right. Beautiful.
Speaker 1: Well, congratulations to
Minnesota for voting and we'll see what
things look like in the fall.
Speaker 3: Yeah, thanks.
Speaker 1: All right. Thank you for
the call. Very much appreciate it.